[la musique]
tout le monde ici
risques et aventures sur le travail de yubiki
et vous êtes d'un fonds d'investissement sous c'est le vôtre de
monstre il bondit du système de lumière et
la plupart des poches.
milich n'est pas assez getz et cela signifie à nouveau
s'il vous plaît répéter ce que nous préparons
hacks quels objets et publiez votre
à partir de
nous n'avons pas de tels programmes depuis
nous mais c'est juste un autre non-sens que nous avons
L'Iran a des projets de coopération dans
nombre dans le domaine de la coopération militaro-technique
tout cela dans le cadre des décisions qui ont été
d'accord sur
dans notre programme nucléaire iranien
Programme nucléaire iranien
dans
Les décisions de l'ONU ainsi que nos
partenaires de formation avec VPD où sur
une certaine étape des sanctions de l'iran
doivent être supprimés, y compris dans la zone
coopération militaro-technique
nous avons certains programmes mais ceci
tout comme d'habitude
l'armement si l'on en vient à cela pendant que nous
nous n'y sommes même pas allés pendant que nous étions avec nous
il n'y a pas de réelle collaboration
sur le terrain sur les armes conventionnelles donc
quelque chose là-bas quelqu'un vient avec
technologies spatiales modernes
juste de la fantaisie juste une autre farce
faux je n'y connais rien
en tout cas ceux qui en parlent
dis mieux que moi navi
nuit déjà
écouter ce que nous discutons des problèmes
qui n'existent pas il n'y a pas de sujet pour
discussions quelqu'un invente quelque chose que je n'invente pas
sais peut-être que c'est lié à la farce
afin de limiter tout
coopération militaro-technique avec
l'Iran
Je le répète, c'est simple
faux trucs dont j'ai généralement
rien n'est connu et je suis de toi
J'entends pour la première fois que nous n'avons pas de telles intentions
ne sais pas si la technologie est prête
accepter même une telle coopération
un sujet séparé est très high-tech
oui en effet nous n'excluons pas que
peut-être notre coopération avec
de nombreux pays du monde pays du monde en
espace mais probablement bien connu de tous
notre position sur ce que nous
fortement opposé à la militarisation
l'espace en général, nous croyons que l'espace
doit être exempt de toute sorte
armes dans l'espace proche de la Terre
posté et ainsi de suite donc nous avons
pas de tels plans
notamment sur le transfert de certaines technologies
du niveau qu'ils viennent de dire
eux-mêmes
ken levine windows et mac os ou avant
s'ouvrira et spécialement demoyan devi était
démocratie où et pourquoi je connais quelqu'un
sert avec une telle sauce que quelqu'un regarde
sur l'évolution de la situation et sur votre
soumis obéissant service différemment
donc c'est servi tout est servi
au public selon ce qui est jugé approprié
pour les classes dirigeantes de l'un ou de l'autre
le pays est que le président Biden
rencontre ses alliés qu'ils ne sont pas
rien d'inhabituel
Eh bien, pourquoi est-ce généralement une réunion des sept que nous
nous savons ce qu'est le sept et il y avait
à plusieurs reprises
Je connais la valeur de c sur ce site mais
quand les gens se rassemblent et discutent de quelque chose
c'est toujours bien mieux que pas
se réunir et ne pas discuter parce que sur
et dans le cadre des sept il y a aussi sur
problèmes nécessitant une attention constante
considération parce que si
contradictions, peu importe comment il semble
étrange
il y a différentes évaluations de certains événements
sur la scène internationale et entre eux bien
bien laisser la recette discuter de quoi
Quant à l'OTAN, j'ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
c'est un vestige de la guerre froide
né à l'époque de la guerre froide
pourquoi existe-t-il aujourd'hui ?
très clair était le moment où ils parlaient
sur le fait qu'elle transforme ce
l'organisation a maintenant besoin de quelque chose à ce sujet
nous avons oublié que nous procédons de ce qu'il est
organisation militaire mais il est allié avec ses
pour quelque chose probablement
de temps en temps besoin d'alliés
rencontrer
bien que pour le même j'imagine comment
il y a une discussion en cours là-bas, eh bien, je comprends
que tout est décidé par consensus, mais quand même
il n'y a qu'un avis valable
le reste n'est pas si propre là-bas
dire
alors pourquoi rencontrer des alliés et
rien d'inhabituel ici
Je ne vois rien d'anormal ici.
surtout un hommage à leur
alliés avant la rencontre des présidents américains
et la russie
eh bien, c'est probablement servi comme un souhait
obtenir leur avis sur des questions clés
ordre du jour moderne, y compris
sur les questions que nous allons
discuter du président acheter des données mais
néanmoins, je suis enclin à penser que malgré
pour toutes ces politesses des États-Unis seront promues
dans les relations avec la Russie, ce qu'ils
jugent nécessaire et important pour eux-mêmes et
d'abord pour vous-même pour vous-même
économique et politique et militaire
intérêts
écoutez ce qu'ils en pensent
les alliés ne lui ont probablement jamais fait de mal
qu'est-ce que le flux de travail
manquer le prix
nous n'avons pas de relation à double sens avant
garanti
au niveau le plus bas de ces dernières années
Cependant, il y a des questions qui nécessitent
comparaison de montres définition de certains
positions mutuelles aux questions
d'intérêt mutuel
résolu plus efficacement dans l'intérêt des deux
États-Unis et Russie
il n'y a donc rien d'anormal ici.
en fait, malgré cela, il semblait
serait une rhétorique dure, nous nous attendions à un tel
offre parce qu'à l'intérieur
l'agenda politique dans les États n'a pas donné
nous la capacité de restaurer
relation à un niveau acceptable
ça aurait dû arriver
tôt ou tard, eh bien, le présent s'en ira
montré une telle initiative avant que vous
vous savez qu'il a soutenu la prolongation du contrat
snv qui n'a pas pu répondre à nos
soutien de la main parce que nous croyons
c'est un traité de confinement
armes stratégiques offensives
suffisamment élaboré répond à nos
intérêts russes et américains
Voilà pourquoi
une telle offre était tout à fait attendue nous
nous savons quelles questions quels problèmes
puis le monde américain avec nous pour discuter de nous
comprendre ces questions et problèmes
nous sommes prêts pour cela dans un travail commun
nous avons certainement sinon
désaccords puis une compréhension différente de la façon dont
rythme et pokemon dans quelles directions
nous devons bouger pour savoir ce qui est
priorité pour la partie américaine
Eh bien, en général, c'est un processus qui
doit être fait professionnellement
par l'intermédiaire du ministère des Affaires étrangères
le Département d'État, respectivement, le Pentagone et
Ministère de la Défense de la Russie à ce
prêt à travailler, nous avons entendu des signaux indiquant que
la partie américaine aimerait
la reprise de ces négociations à un tel
niveau expert professionnel nous
On verra
si après le sommet de
les conditions seront créées pour cela
s'il vous plaît nous ne refusons pas
prêt pour ce travail
demander au monstre de vous faire face et
l'instabilité et l'appeler c'est la chose la plus importante
c'est la valeur la plus importante que l'on puisse dire
affaires internationales si nous pouvions
te donner des tortues et être yurovka
winston ou capital il dit une chose je
Je dis autre chose, mais peut-être un jour dans
que les nôtres diffèrent dans la rhétorique, mais
si vous demandez maintenant mon point
vision
voilà je vous dis ce que c'est
la valeur la plus importante au niveau international
relations est la stabilité et
prévisibilité
mais nous sommes de côté comme je pense de côté
nos partenaires américains juste ce
et vous n'avez pas vu les années précédentes ce que
même stabilité et prévisibilité si
nous nous souviendrons des événements en Libye en 2011
le pays a été détruit, eh bien, c'est comment ici
stabilité et prévisibilité
donc ils en parlaient tout le temps
les troupes en Afghanistan resteront
puis tout d'un coup les troupes sortent
Afghanistan, il est conclu que la stabilité et
prévisibilité
alors voici les événements au moyen-orient
qu'est-ce que la stabilité et la prévisibilité
à quoi tout cela mène-t-il
ou en Syrie par stable vous
prévisible, je vous demanderai de mon
collègues américains, eh bien, vous voulez
pour assad de partir et qui prendre sa place
viens ce qui va se passer ensuite la réponse est étrange
Je ne sais pas, je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer ensuite
changer ce qui est parce que ça peut être 2
libye ou 2 afghanistan nous le voulons
Non
asseyons-nous ensemble
parler chercher des solutions chercher
des compromis acceptables pour toutes les parties
c'est ainsi que la stabilité est atteinte
il ne peut pas être atteint
imposer un point de vue
point de vue correct, tous les autres ne le sont pas
tenue aussi la stabilité n'est pas
atteint
alles dans ce n'est pas sur vous voulez un budu
coupe-disque sur eux, mais je cherche quelque chose qui
ancien président des états-unis mr trump
une personne exceptionnellement talentueuse et je vais commencer
s'il n'était pas devenu président des États-Unis
personne brillante, il peut aimer quelqu'un
peut ne pas aimer bien sûr que non
un produit de l'establishment américain
il avait l'habitude d'être dans une si grande politique
jamais été naturel comme ça
Je n'aime pas ça mais c'est comme ça que le président est
Biden, bien sûr, de manière drastique
Trump est différent parce qu'il
c'est un professionnel toute sa vie
conscient presque en politique il
Je fais ça depuis de nombreuses années
en parler est une évidence
combien d'années a-t-il été sénateur
pendant des années, il a traité des problèmes, disons
désarmement de la politique internationale
en fait au niveau expert
mais c'est une personne différente je suis très
Je pense qu'il y a des avantages et des inconvénients.
qu'il n'y aura pas de tels mouvements impulsifs
par le président sortant
nous respecterons certaines
règles de communication que nous pouvons à propos de quelque chose
accepter de trouver des points
contacter, eh bien, en fait
peut-être tout ce qui arrivera
c'est vraiment à voir
sur la base d'une véritable politique pratique
et et résultats y viré barnes s
les formes ne savent pas comment yu et in chi leur balle
avant de
l'apparition du menu de son compte csl ne prend pas
acheter assez de tyumen
Je ne sais pas pour l'âme, je dois encore penser
quelle est l'âme mais je ne me souviens pas de cette partie
nos conversations, pour être honnête, pas
souviens-toi mais nous tous quand nous nous rencontrons
nous parlons nous travaillons nous réalisons
certaines décisions dans lesquelles nous agissons
intérêts de leurs États de leurs peuples
et c'est la base de tous nos
actions de pensées et et c'est
motivation pour l'organisation
réunions de ce genre
âmes ceci à l'église s'il vous plaît je vais augmenter
résumé du site italki chuev ice l'a écrit
ne se souvient pas que ma mémoire est devenue son mur et
ils ont une bonne mémoire
Je suppose que je ne l'exclus pas, je ne m'en souviens pas
en général, dans les rencontres personnelles, les gens
essayer de se comporter correctement
ne se souvient pas des éléments invalides
comportement de mes collègues jusqu'à présent
pour l'instant rien de tel mais peut-être
il a dit quelque chose ici il alors je ne je ne le fais pas
rappelez-vous leur conception
bien, selon le contexte dans lequel
quelle forme comprenez-vous
Peut-on dire autrement
être déposé mais généralement les gens
se réunir pour réparer
relations et créer les conditions
travailler ensemble pour atteindre
des résultats positifs et si
vous devez régler les choses aussi, pas d'autre
dogging comme on dit en Russie
Je jure avec pourquoi donc rencontrer le temps
dépenser mieux pour régler les problèmes
politiques sociales budgétaires à l'intérieur
côté nous avons beaucoup de questions que nous
doit décider mais quel est le point
quelle perte de temps tout
peut bien sûr postuler
mais à l'intérieur de la consommation politique quoi
Je pense que les États-Unis sont le dernier
années zone d'idées russo-américaine
les relations ont été sacrifiées
tout le temps politique intérieure aiguë
lutte politique intérieure
usa ces vidéos nous connaissent bien dans quelque chose
seulement pas privé pas accusé
choix d'intervention et toujours là
cyberattaques et ainsi de suite, et pas un seul
pas une seule fois pas une seule fois
pris la peine de montrer quelques
la preuve vient d'être acceptée
blâme je suis surpris pourquoi encore nous
pas blâmé pour ce que nous avons provoqué
mouvement des vies noires comptent
quelle serait une bonne ligne comme celle-ci
mais nous ne l'avons pas fait je pense que c'est
bien sûr la politique intérieure est un mouvement
a été utilisé par l'un des
forces pendant la campagne électorale, mais sous cette
il y a certaines raisons
rappelez-vous que le curry a couru dans le caprolon
qui était à la fois secrétaire d'État aux
le Pentagone a mené la sienne ou
a écrit que même lui est un haut gradé
officiel
toute sa vie, il a ressenti une sorte de
l'injustice à l'égard de soi-même comme comment
une personne à la peau foncée
L'époque soviétique et nous en Russie nous avons toujours
nous avons toujours
étaient sympathiques à la lutte
les Afro-Américains pour leurs droits et cela
Il a
a des racines de base définies mais dans
en même temps si
quels que soient les nobles objectifs
quelqu'un ne vous guide pas si c'est le cas
va à l'extrême
quelque
dans certains acquiert certains éléments
l'extrémisme, bien sûr, nous ne pouvons pas
bienvenue et nous avons ici
la relation est très simple donc nous
soutenir la lutte des Afro-Américains pour
nos droits, mais nous sommes contre tout type
[la musique]
l'extrémisme l'extrémisme que nous
parfois . malheureusement je regarde maintenant
et de moins en moins de cheveux avec des tresses
escadron microsoft obtient même une arme à feu
iceiceice et ont été attirés par elle
au lieu de chemin au lieu de corriger ils
femmes guerrières de la croix de chêne maroc
cher ki tu as dit qu'il y a un tout
ensemble de preuves de cyberattaques de l'extérieur
Russie
puis répertorié où
départements américains officiels
qui ont déclaré cela à propos de leur canon avec
oui oui vous me donnez des informations à ce sujet
Qui a dit où est la preuve
que c'était fait je te comprends
Je dirai ceci ceci ceci ceci a dit ceci a dit
et où est la preuve d'une telle
accusations non fondées je peux vous dire
répondre
vous pouvez vous plaindre à la ligue internationale
réforme sexuelle
ça te conviendra mais c'est simple
parler de rien mais au moins de quelque chose
positivement un tableau pour qu'ils puissent voir
et y réagir d'une manière ou d'une autre, mais cela
il n'y a rien de tout cela, voici le dernier
Je connais l'un des derniers de si
était sur le système de pipeline américain
méchant et qui met souvent majesta
autant que je sache, les actionnaires
cette société a même décidé
payer la rançon qu'ils ont payée cyber
bandits mais si vous avez énuméré un ensemble
ensemble de services spéciaux américains
respectés, ils sont puissants à l'échelle mondiale, mais ils
peut trouver ceux qui ont reçu une rançon dans
à la fin ou pas, j'espère qu'ils
assurez-vous que la Russie est dans ce
tout de suite quelle attitude
à présent
une sorte de cyberattaque sur une usine de transformation de viande
certains là puis sur des oeufs peints
diront que leur attaque est parfaitement comprise
il suffit de se transformer en certains
farce
de comme une farce sans fin mais aussi
et vous avez dit beaucoup de preuves
mais pas un seul n'a été accepté à nouveau, mais
ces mêmes conversations sont simplement vides dans
profitent assez bien aux pauvres de quoi parlons-nous
on se dit oui même avec tel il est le prix du leur
la façon dont vous savez est la plus simple
nous devrions manger en paix et
accepter de travailler ensemble
cyberespace, nous avons proposé ce
l'administration de monsieur obama
quelque part en octobre a commencé en septembre
offert l'année dernière
présidence de bélier
ils étaient silencieux au début quelque part en novembre
répondu que oui c'est intéressant alors
donc nous avons perdu les élections
déjà répété cette offre
l'administration d'atout nous
a répondu que c'était intéressant mais donc un combat
les vraies négociations ne sont pas venues ici
il y a des raisons de croire que nous pouvons
construire des travaux dans ce domaine avec un nouveau
J'espère que l'administration
alignements politiques intérieurs aux états-unis
n'empêche pas de le faire, mais nous
offert ce travail, rejoignons-nous
voyons ce que nous pouvons obtenir
s'entendre sur des principes
travailler ensemble pour convenir de la manière
nous nous y opposerons
un processus qui prend de l'ampleur dans notre
eux-mêmes dans la Fédération de Russie même
le nombre de cybercrimes a augmenté en
fois dernièrement au niveau national nous
par conséquent
essayer de réagir à la recherche de ces
cybercriminels si nous découvrons
punir et nous sommes également prêts à travailler avec
acteurs de la communication internationale
y compris les états mais ci-dessous vous refuse
refuser de travailler ensemble
pouvons-nous faire cela nous ne pouvons pas faire cela
construire de l'eau unilatéralement
elle a longtemps été triste stansky
japonais enfin un jeune homme de russie fotini
nuvole
tu sais comme pour la guerre, disons
l'otan officiellement je veux transformer votre
attention à
a officiellement annoncé qu'il croit
kiba royaume du cyberespace combat
actions et mener des exercices militaires dans
cyberespace on n'en parle pas
la longueur dentaire en a retiré la nôtre
fioritures attaquées
non non non ce n'est pas si bien amené ici
si nous voulions le faire nous le ferions aussi
L'OTAN a déclaré qu'elle pensait
cyberespace de guerre
et préparer et même conduire des exercices mais
michelle noire a dit que tu étais tellement et
nous le ferons mais nous ne le voulons pas
nous aimons simplement ne pas vouloir de militarisation
l'espace, nous ne voulons pas sa militarisation
processus cyber et offre plusieurs fois
convenir d'un travail commun sur le terrain
Sécurité
donc la direction est votre intendant
refuse si le nouveau ils encore
mais nous comptons sur le fait que personne
doit intervenir dans 3 politiques
processus dans un autre pays que l'amérique
notre lui et dans l'américain aucun autre
il faut donner au peuple la possibilité de tous les pays
je sauverai le monde
se développer calmement même s'il y a
situation de crise, ils devraient
autorisé par la population à l'intérieur du pays sans
ingérence extérieure, mais il me semble que
cet appel à l'administration américaine
y compris l'administration d'aujourd'hui
ne vaut pas grand chose parce que je
il semble que le gouvernement américain
va interférer avec vous
processus politiques dans d'autres pays
ce processus est peu probable
arrêter un chiffre d'affaires très important
marqué mais de travailler ensemble dans
cyberespace sur la prévention
empêcher toute situation inacceptable
actions des cybercriminels
les cybercriminels sont certainement possibles
nous avons hâte de leur parler
Que pouvons-nous faire
ce processus, en collaboration avec l'américain
vous serez partenaires et fila en amérique
Les dépenses des chars jamaïcains rêvaient de se lever
réunissons-nous demain matin
Je ne le ferais pas si j'étais en Amérique, que suis-je
peur si j'étais américain ou quoi
ils disent en général romeo quiz bon
nokia et qui savait et reine il site bien et
tu le sais aussi comme la militarisation
l'espace est une zone très dangereuse ou
parfois afin d'atteindre dans
sphère nucléaire dans la sphère de la confrontation
domaines
les armes nucléaires ont convenu le même soviétique
union et etats unis
sur le point de retenir cette course
des armes, mais le cyberespace est
zones très sensibles aujourd'hui
les technologies numériques sont très
nombreuses activités humaines et
mise en œuvre des fonctions publiques
bien sûr, les interventions dans ces processus
peut causer de graves dommages
dommage mais quand même je le comprends au troisième
encore une fois asseyons-nous et soyons
accepter de travailler ensemble sur
la sécurité dans ce domaine
c'est tout ce qui n'est pas une mauvaise question ici
Je comprends même je ne veux pas te demander
laisser une situation difficile mais pour moi
quant à un citoyen ordinaire, ce serait
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ils refusent
vos projets refusent cette charge
continuer à travers les couleurs jusqu'à
y intervenir dans des cyberattaques sur sur sur
une place dans une usine de transformation de la viande, c'est-à-dire la nôtre
proposition d'entamer des négociations sur ce
sujet
s'écarter des bêtises quoi mais c'est pareil
c'est exactement ce qui se passe bien en répétant
Encore une fois, j'espère que nous pourrons atteindre
travail positif dans ce domaine ce qu'il y a
peur
pourquoi proposons-nous d'être d'accord parce que
quelque chose qui peut être craint en Amérique comme
pourrait être dangereux pour
nous etats unis
côté high tech si otan
annoncé que le cyberespace est
l'étendue des hostilités, cela signifie donc qu'ils
quelque chose est prévu là-bas
le cuisinier bien sûr ne peut s'empêcher de vous exciter
ne t'inquiète pas pour nous, tu es Fedor Tomich, je n'ai pas peur
mais je veux dire que c'est possible
Qui a dit ce qui nous fait peur ou
méta position l'a dit
et d'aventurine cheval lui c'est toi
le présenter comme une dissidence et
intolérance à la dissidence en Russie
la mayonnaise le regarde complètement différemment
vous avez mentionné la loi sur les étrangers
agents
mais ce n'est pas notre invention c'est toujours dans
Loi sur les agents étrangers des années 1930
a été adopté aux USA et c'est beaucoup plus
dur que le nôtre envoyé y compris
pour éviter toute interférence avec
vie politique interne de l'union
états et en général, en général, je crois que
envoyé vous voulez que je réponde
les feuilles de match me suffisent pour répondre
toi maintenant je regarde maintenant
Je vais jeter un œil à Minsk, laissez-moi le prendre
répondra survécu a posé une question à vous pas
J'aime ma réponse et j'ai tout de suite
l'interrompre incorrectement signifie donc
cela signifie qu'en Amérique, cela a longtemps été accepté
la loi ça marche et les sanctions sont beaucoup
plus dur que le nôtre jusqu'à la privation
la liberté ainsi de suite le joueur introduira
bien que je le donne à dtd mais maintenant je vais dire
Je reviens tout de suite, ne vous inquiétez pas, je vais
Je ne resterai pas uniquement sur le site des problèmes
fils quelque chose maintenant je serai de retour
commenter ce qui se passe
encore non non tu me dis juste si tu
sois patient laisse moi parler
à la fin ce que je veux tout te dire
deviendra clair
mais tu n'aimes pas ma réponse tu n'aimes pas
tu veux que ma réponse soit entendue par toi
téléspectateurs c'est le problème que vous fermez
moi la bouche
développé la liberté d'expression
opinions ou est-ce la liberté d'expression
sa propre opinion sur l'Amérique
les raisons
Sanka est toute au centre d'elle-même, mais si
cela signifie qu'aux États-Unis une loi a été adoptée, nous
il a été récemment adopté dans le but de
protéger notre société des ingérences
de l'extérieur c'est si dans certains états
des observateurs étrangers approchent
dit le procureur du bureau de vote
encore quelques mètres plus près et
Je vais te mettre en prison, c'est normal et ça
la démocratie par la modernité
et dans certains États cette pratique
nous n'avons rien de tel quand je
parler de ces lois de non-intervention
ou tentatives d'interventions que j'ai
en vue de la Russie, voici de nombreux
structures
soi-disant société civile
dire pourquoi soi-disant ils
financé à l'étranger est en préparation
programme d'action pertinent
activiste en formation
à l'étranger et lorsque notre fonctionnaire
les structures le voient avec un but
empêcher de telles interférences
nos affaires internes nous acceptons
décision et les lois appropriées et ils
plus doux que le vôtre, nous en avons un comme ça
proverbe
il n'y a rien à reprocher au miroir si la tasse
courbe
c'est super de n'avoir rien à faire mais
si nous blâmons quelqu'un pour quelque chose
alors regarde toi tu te vois dans
miroir pour nous voir il n'y a rien ici
inhabituel
en ce qui concerne l'activité politique et
le système politique dans lequel il se développe
nous avons 44 lots enregistrés 34 lavages
1:32 participera à divers
élu pour
processus partout en septembre afin
nous avons eu de l'opposition et avons roulé et fait
J'ai une opposition non systématique à vous
ils ont dit que quelqu'un a été détenu quelqu'un
est en prison jusqu'à
c'est aussi beaucoup de bain mentionné
quelques noms de famille
oui oui oui dis encore alors maintenant je vais dire
Je vais vous dire maintenant si je ne manque pas une chose
une question ne t'inquiete pas
vous lancer pour tout ce que les moustiques g-code
Alexei Navalny pour son fils signifie toujours
Bien sûr que non, nous n'avons pas cette habitude.
tuer quelqu'un est le premier deuxième moyen
Je veux te demander et tu as commandé
tuer une femme qui est entrée au congrès et
abattu par un flic que tu connais
que vous avez 450 personnes arrêtées après
appelant au congrès et ils ne sont pas venus oui vous
quoi voler l'ordinateur avec lequel ils sont venus
revendications politiques 450 chèque
arrêtés, ils ne risquent pas la prison
emprisonnement
ils risquent des peines de prison de 15 à
25 ans et ils sont venus avec des politiques
conditions
N'est-ce pas la persécution
les opinions politiques de certains sont blâmées
dans un complot pour prendre le pouvoir
certains sont même accusés de vol
n'est pas venu pour voler signifie les gens que vous êtes
mentionné
Oui, ils ont été reconnus coupables d'avoir violé le régime
les personnes qui ont été condamnées à l'épreuve
au moins deux fois une personne a été condamnée en probation
essentiellement, il a simplement été averti de ne pas
violé le russe
législateur pas de mépris total
les exigences de la loi à la fin le tribunal
pris une décision appropriée en changeant
mesure préventive pour garder sous
gardes aux dépens de tels
en tel je te dirai un an en Russie
des milliers qui violent le régime conditionnel
contenu marqué comme ignoré
les exigences de la loi sont des milliers et ils n'ont pas
rien à voir avec la politique
activités si quelqu'un se cache derrière
activités politiques
mais pour résoudre leurs propres affaires
y compris commercial puis pertinent
comment y répondre et comment
repérer l'eau qui passe en la plaçant sur vous
et tu es banal avec nous de chine avec
maidan tu jettes sur frappe l'océan sur
Kane à
à savoir textile donner que McCain fr
tanga du pire film comment faire un
transféré à son c'est parti pour la dernière expiration
étaient de lui
aquino il a dit 16 en face d'une jaquena
auditeur auquel je suis habitué pendant mon temps
travailler à des attaques de différents côtés sur très
de nombreuses occasions et de qualité différente et
boutades
rien ne nous surprend avec ces gens
avec qui nous travaillons
nous nous disputons sur la scène internationale, nous ne
les mariés ne jurent pas à la dure
amour et amitié éternels
nous sommes partenaires et dans quelque chose nous sommes en concurrence les uns avec les autres
ami, voici la chose
rhétorique dure, il me semble que cela
manifestation générale de partiellement général
la culture américaine bien sûr disons dans
Hollywood est
souvenait d'Hollywood au début de notre
les conversations ont des choses profondes qui
peut certainement être attribué au travail
arts de la cinématographie
mais le plus souvent c'est un tel machisme comme ça
comme si dans l'américain y compris
la culture politique est considérée
d'accord, au fait, nous n'avons pas de chagrin, mais si
cette rhétorique est suivie d'une phrase
rencontrer et discuter bilatéralement
questions questions de politique internationale je
Je le prends comme une envie de
travailler ensemble si c'est ce que vous voulez
sérieux nous sommes prêts à le soutenir
de jones à la salle de classe la personne vous a répondu
Je répondrai maintenant si je le permets
donc j'ai entendu des dizaines de telles accusations
surtout dans nos moments difficiles
dans le domaine de
temps sur notre lutte contre le terrorisme sur
Caucase du Nord
je suis toujours guidé
intérêts de l'Etat russe et
peuple russe et ces maximes sur
à propos de ce qui est-il qu'est-ce qu'il est
les appels ils s'en foutent complètement
Anapa
écoute mais tu sais que je ne le fais pas
Je veux paraître grossier mais il semble
sur quelqu'un comme ça
indigestion uniquement verbale
listé
beaucoup de gens qui ont vraiment
souffert est mort à des moments différents
différentes raisons aux mains de différentes personnes sous
feuilles sur vous avez mentionné
il travaillait dans mon administration
il a été très bien traité, il est mort en
Les États-Unis sont morts ou sont morts, je ne sais pas, eh bien, vous
Je dois demander comment il est mort là-bas
par exemple, c'est quand même dommage que je l'ai trouvé
la vie à mon avis est très décente
personne décente
comme pour les autres quelqu'un à propos de nous
trouvé quelqu'un qui n'est pas de ces criminels
lequel
commis certains crimes
donc quelqu'un est en prison
nous sommes prêts à continuer à travailler dans le même
touche verre en mode révèle tout alors
par leurs actions infligent ce qui va
contre la loi et par leurs actions
endommage l'image
Fédération Russe
mais comme ça, jetez tout d'affilée
juste insensé incorrect n'a pas
complice de leurs fondations mais si
imaginez-le comme une ligne
attaques s'il vous plaît écoutons ça
Je répète encore et je l'ai entendu
plusieurs fois mais ça ne me fait pas du tout
confus je sais quoi
sens de déplacement pour
assurer les intérêts de la Russie
États
[la musique]